[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to their installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the weasley twins
fred and george more specifically we're
going to be discussing
the differences between the pair fred
and george are the fourth
and fifth born children of arthur and
molly weasley
they were born in the year 1978 and it's
probably no surprise to anyone
to their identical twins this means that
they're physically identical in nearly
every way however the twins are extra
similar
in that they also share very similar
personality traits
in fact most of the time it's hard to
tell them apart
given that they are so similar today i
want to explore how we can actually
determine
which one is which additionally i wanted
to take a look at their individual
contributions to the series
to see if one twin is more significant
than the other
from the perspective of the story only
first things first
one has to be older right well yeah
it turns out that when they were born on
april 1st 1978
fred popped out first so he must be the
older
wiser brother right tragically fred was
also the first of the brothers to die
suffering an untimely death during the
battle of hogwarts
jk rowling has revealed that fred's
death was one of the hardest to write in
however she did also reveal that fred
was the chosen brother to die
because he was slightly more conspicuous
suggesting that fred plays a slightly
larger role in the books
films than george actually it turns out
that fred is mentioned over 900 times in
the books
while george is only mentioned around
700 times
the reason for this is not entirely
clear however
it may be because fred is the slightly
more vocal brother
the one who is more likely to act and
speak first
from pottermore when you read through
the books you can see that it was almost
always fred who spoke first
usually a joke or dramatic comment he
was the front man
the lead singer the one who first got
everyone's attention
george was the slightly more
level-headed twin who explained what his
brother
actually meant fred even passed george
the task of explaining the marauders map
to harry
when he could have done so himself in
fact while harrigan was close to both of
the twins
he had longer conversations with george
who often explained events harry might
have missed
plans he and fred had or things harry
didn't quite understand
fred and george really did complement
each other perfectly
additionally fred was the instigator for
most of their pranks
george simply followed suit whenever the
weasley twins did something particularly
naughty
it always seemed to be fred who took the
lead when the twins and ron broke harry
out of privet drive in his second year
it was fred who was driving the flying
ford anglia he was usually the one
behind even the smaller pranks
fred was the one who liberated a
salamander from care of magical
creatures
so they could try to feed it filibuster
firework and fred was the one who
accidentally dropped a ton tongue toffee
in front of dudley
did you ever notice that it's always
fred and george and not
george and fred fred spoke first and
george explained second
which almost makes george's
circumstances after fred's death
even sadder the two were inseparable for
their entire lives
and provided that fred was the front man
george was probably quite lost after the
war
after years of following the actions of
his twin and never really having to take
action
himself in life they spent nearly every
waking moment together
they had a beautiful friendship and
interestingly enough the books don't
really delve much
into what actually happened to george
after the death of his brother
losing any kind of friend or family
member is horrendous
but to lose a twin must be soul
destroying after the death of fred
what happened to george in the
documentary jk rowling a year in the
life
rowling dives into the weasley family
tree and mentions the following with
regards to george
a lot of readers ask me was george all
right and of course he wouldn't be all
right would he
that's the reality but i think that he
married angelina
who was actually fred's ex maybe it's a
bit unhealthy
but i think they would have been happy
as happy as he could be without fred
i think he really would have felt like
part of himself died
additionally rowling was asked about
george weasley's state
in a 2007 interview with bloomsbury how
is george getting along without his twin
well i don't think that george would
ever get over losing fred which makes me
feel so sad
however he names his first child and son
fred and he goes on to have a very
successful career
helped by good old ron the interview
also confirms that george continued
working at the business which he and his
brother had created
ron joined george at weasley's wizarding
wheezes
which became an enormous money spinner
these are quite tragic answers from
rolling
but it's good to see that she isn't
softening the truth losing a family
member is one of the worst things that
we have to deal with
in life effectively yes life would go on
for george
but it would never be the same his
companion the person that he had shared
every moment with since childhood was
gone would he be happy again
would he experience joy again yes of
course
but would george weasley be changed
forever after the passing of his brother
absolutely so how else did these twin
brothers
who were nearly identical in every way
operate as individuals
while fred was a bit more outgoing and
inclined to do a bit of damage
him and george were almost the perfect
combo because george was always there to
mitigate the damage
however don't get me wrong george was
happy to do so
he would have never wanted his twin's
demeanor to change and was happy to take
on damage control after his brother
opened his mouth
fred and george were both undeniably
charismatic but george was
as it were the public face of the weezy
twins able to be
much more subtle and diplomatic than
fred george was the twin who made edits
their letter to ludo bagman
knowing that certain wording would sound
accusatory and was the one who realized
why hermione wanted to get into the
school kitchens
he was even the one who remembered to
get the new common room password from a
prefect
but not only were their personalities
different they were also
unsurprisingly not identical in athletic
performance
athleticism will vary largely on an
individual basis
and it just so happens that george was
the better athlete
what game quidditch what position beta
while both fred and george were
excellent beaters and a credit to the
gryffindor quidditch team
there were more mentions of george
hitting bludgers than there were of fred
george seemed to be the slightly more
aggressive of the two on the quidditch
pitch
described once as hitting a bludger at a
player as a way of
venting his feelings and retaliating for
a foul
by elbowing a slytherin beta in the face
lastly i want to explore if there's a
way to tell them apart
physically are there any key differences
that can help us to spot which one is
which
this next part is going to be exploring
the characters from the films
as the real-life actors oliver and james
phelps
do in fact have some subtle differences
in their physical appearance
for reference oliver plays george and
james plays fred
i got the following information from a
source i've never heard of
online so hopefully it's accurate it
turns out that george
oliver has a longer straighter and
slightly thinner face
the slightly differently set jaw he also
has a mole on the right side of his neck
has slightly more slanted eyes that are
less deep has a slightly longer and
curved
nose with a bump has a slightly crooked
smile
and is slightly taller than fred james
fred can be characterized by a shorter
rounder face
a scar on his left eyebrow less slanted
deeper eyes
a straight nose and a slightly shorter
stature
and i think that about summarizes all
the differences between fred
george did you guys learn something i
know that i didn't know all of this
until researching for the video
did anything surprise you let me know in
the comment section
below until next time remember ask us no
questions
and will tell you no lies
you